hello there i hope you have
all seen this this is a new system by
facebook ai
and what you're seeing here is a
visualization of the
attention maps of that neural network
in the middle is a supervised baseline
and on the right is this new
system called dyno it's not as much a
system
as it is a methodology for unsupervised
pre-training of visual transformers
and you can see that the system has
neither been trained
to learn what a dog is nor has it been
trained to do any sort of segmentation
yet if you look at the
attention maps it clearly can
track objects it knows what to pay
attention to
in the images and it can do much more
than that so here you can see
that it can sort of track objects behind
occlusions so the ship goes behind the
waves
the horse goes behind the grass and
you can see in the attention map that
these
this is well reflected
you can do more than that though even so
if you
use this feature representation that
this model gives you
for imagenet then as the model gets
trained
and you represent imagenet in its
feature space
it will cluster the same the images of
the same class it will cluster them
together which is already pretty cool
because it
it has no labels at training time but
also it will
cluster similar classes uh
with each other which you know
speaks to the it kind of speaks to the
fact that this might be
the next step in unsupervised
representation learning for images
and specifically it appears that the
features
that come out of a network that is
trained with dyno
are extremely valuable for the kinds of
things we
you know we are interested in when
working with natural images
so this is image retrieval
and classification so this system
let's just switch over to the paper
right here the paper is called
emerging properties in self-supervised
vision transformers it it presents a
system called
dino it's by matilde cajon hugo duvro
is
of facebook air research indriya and
sorbonne university
you can see a bit more here in in these
in these pictures where again this is
the
self attention so the the attention map
from
a vision transformer that was trained
with dyno and no supervision
okay and you can clearly see that in all
the cases
the attention falls on
what you would consider as a human the
the relevant
things in the image now i have my
hypotheses
why this is the case like completely
without labels and
we'll we'll see about that but the
representations that come out of the
systems
um are really useful for example you can
fine-tune
uh linear classifiers on top of these
representations and get that
gives you really good image classifiers
they do that with imagenet
you can use these for image retrieval
because
similar images are clustered together
you can
use even do zero shot classification
simply by doing a k
nearest neighbor classifier in that
feature space
um and yeah here you can also do some
sort of
proto image segmentation by looking at
the attention maps you don't even have
to do something special to visualize
this like you have to do in cnns
the attention map directly gives you the
the sort of segmentation map or or
something pretty close to it
as an overview this system dyno is
simply a they push the self-supervised
learning and they specifically make the
case that
self-supervised and visual transformer
they go together really well and
they as i said the dino is called self
distillation with no labels
so it does that is die no
and um yeah they they push
various kind of metrics in
in in the self-supervised systems or
you know then linear classifier trained
on top of them
for example 80.1 percent top one on
imagenet in
linear evaluation with the with a
visual transformer base
a quick overview over the system is
right here
so two things they say are important
next to all the other self-supervised
systems
first of all they do they have a kind of
student
teacher that's the self-distillation
part
the teacher is a momentum teacher
and it does this centering and it also
does
sharpening in the softmax right here and
then there is no contrastive learning
there's no negative samples
that the sharpening and the centering
sort of take care
of keeping the model from moat collapse
or from collapsing also there's no batch
norm so
if those things don't don't mean
anything to you
maybe stay tuned we'll we'll discuss
them in a bit more detail as we go
through the paper
if you like paper uh summaries like this
and other
content for example our cooking video
uh feel free to share this out and tell
your friends about it by the way the
cooking video did terribly
i don't know why um i guess
i guess my youtuber skills are just not
not on par but yeah i don't know
yeah if anyone has any ideas all right
let's dive in
so vision transformers are a new thing
right vision transformers um i've
also made a video about vision
transformers
they are the easy the simple application
of the transformer architecture
which was prevalent in
natural language processing with the
introduction of
attention is all you need and follow-up
papers burped
and so on and applying this
to images and the concept is very simple
uh you have an image and you divide this
into patches
so you divide the image into patches
and then you simply unroll that array
sort of so you
unroll that array so you have patch
patch patch
patch and so on and then you simply
consider
this as a sequence like a sentence like
hello my name is and so on
you simply consider the sequence of
patches as
word embeddings so there is like one i
think there is one
fully connected layer to actually get
the word embedding
or the token embedding and then you put
a
transformer as you would in nlp
so there is a transformer
here and you do whatever you do with the
transformer so
usually if you don't know
people prepend a special token that
special token is usually called
something where am i going to draw this
that special token is usually called
cls token and that is also
passed through the transformer and the
transformer
in its base configuration it sort of
keeps
it keeps the length of the sequence the
same it's actually not necessary to do
this but
that's just how we do things so for
every input token you'll get a
corresponding
output token or output embedding or
output signal
or whatever you want to call it and
such that none of the input tokens
is you know kind of preferred because
every input token
sort of refers to some little patch here
in the image
if you want to say something about the
entire image you don't want to
prefer any one of them so what you do is
you have this special token the cls
token
which is associated with no location in
the image and
that's ultimately what you use to
classify the image or also here to do
representation learning so the
representation we're looking to get out
is the final layer embedding of the cls
token and that through the transformer
architecture
had aggregated all the information or we
hope so
from all the visual tokens in the image
so that's a visual transformer now what
do we do with it
in this dino architecture i've already
shown you this picture let's go
a little bit deeper into that
self-supervised
learning naturally means you have no
labels and
in this case you don't even have a
negative
sample mechanism or a contrastive
learning mechanism
so what you want to do is you want to
train
a model that sort of gives you gives you
sensible
representations and that is
easier said than done if you have no
labels
um now the when you do contrastive
learning
the goal is that you
have an image and you just take
two patches from the image let's say and
you have another image
and you take a patch from that and now
you
have what's called your anchor this is
your anchor
and then you have patch patch a
from the same patch b now you present
the model
all the three patches and you tell it
which one is the anchor and
it needs to decide is the
patch a or patch b from the same image
you can see
how this objective can give you sort of
representation because the model learns
what kind of stuff is likely to be in
the same image
this is not the case right here we don't
do contrastive learning we don't have
negative samples we only
we take one image and then we
augment that image in different ways now
augmentations are a kind of a science by
itself i think
they say they follow the paper b-y-o-l
in terms of augmentations i've also made
a video on that
essentially what you do is you do
various random perturbations of the
image you might flip it you might
apply some color jitter you might apply
like some solarization
um anything like this anything you can
do
to make the image different but
that you're relatively sure that you
know it still looks like the same
like you would still recognize it as the
same image
so a part of these augmentations are
also crops
what i've shown you here are crops of
the same image
they do something special right here
when they have an image they
crop in two different ways one they call
i think global crops
and these are crops which generally
cover more than 50
of the image whereas the other ones they
called
local crops and these are crops that
cover
less than 50 of the image
okay this is going to be important in
in one was so this these are global and
these are local
crops uh of the same image
so they um
exactly and keep that in mind and now we
have to understand
what's up with this student and this
teacher
so what we ideally want to do is we want
to have
two different augmentations of the same
image so here we have an image
and you can see we make two different
versions
of that image now this could be two
different crops and then we apply two
different color jitters
we applied two different random
rotations and so on we just want
two different versions of the same image
and our goal finally is going to be
here you can see the loss is that the
representation we get out of it
is the same so we teach the network that
look these two things
they might look different you know
but they are in fact the same
they are you know from there's crops
differently augmented differently
cropped but from the same image
so the easiest thing would be to just
pass the two
through the same network but that it
does not work
um so if you don't have negative samples
your main goal is to avoid what's called
collapse
if the network just maps everything to
the same representation
then it always wins right it always is
like well
you know okay the the two things are the
same because everything's the same
you don't want that so a trick is to
have two different models
one you call the student and one you
call the teacher and they're called
student and teacher
because uh from from distillation
so in distillation what you usually have
is you have a data set
and then you train a big model
which is the teacher and
now what you want to do is you want to
make you want
to make that model maybe smaller right
such that it runs on a mobile phone
and that's then the student and there is
a procedure
where you take the data set and you take
the teacher model
and you sort of transfer the knowledge
from the teacher model to the student
model
while using you can use the data set to
do so
and that usually works better than
training the student model from scratch
it's very
interesting why that even works but this
process is called
distillation so that's why it's called
teacher and student
however in this case it's kind of a
self-distillation so the teacher and the
student
they're not big or small they're the
same architectures
in fact we only train the student
okay and the teacher is
made from the student so here is where
the the terms break down a bit
like um so in the distillation sense the
teacher is
the teacher in the distillation but now
it breaks down because the teacher is
constructed from the student
so we have a teacher we train the
student to predict the same thing as the
teacher does
like learning from the teacher but then
at the same time
after we have done after we've updated
the student we then
have we then build the teacher from the
new student
and the way we do this you can see right
here is by exponentially moving
average so we keep the teacher model
and then as we update the student model
we simply update the teacher a little
bit into the direction of the student
model
and there is also a schedule associated
with this
exponentially moving average like how
much the exponential decay is
and so on this seems all to be loaded
with hyper parameters
um but again the results are really cool
and it it i guess it's yet gonna turn
out
how sensitive to hyper parameters this
whole setup
is they do make ablations but
yeah no we'll see how other people with
other data sets fare
all right so we have the teacher that is
built from the student exponentially
moving average
and we want to make the two predict
the same represents or the same output
four different augmentations
of the same image okay in fact
here you see um
it's even a bit more complicated so this
is the pseudo code
so we want to augment the image we get
two different
versions of the image we push both of
these versions
through the student and through the
teacher right
and then um we want
if you i don't know if you can if you
can track if you can track that but
t1 is the
x1 that went through the teacher it
that needs to be the same as x2
that went through the student and then
the
image x2 went through the teacher should
be the same as x1 going through the
student
so we want to augment the image
differently
two times then that gives us two
different
views of the same image then we want to
run them through the both through the
teacher and student
and then we want sort of everything to
be consistent with
everything else so we want the one
augmentation in the one model to be
consistent with another augmentation
through another model
now there are two more things here
um the first one is these centering
what's called centering and that's what
something the teacher does and also
something they say in the text is that
in the teacher they only use
the global cropping
whereas in the student they use both the
global
and the local cropping so the student
uses both and the teacher only uses
the global crops so essentially if the
student
gets a local crop and the teacher gets a
global crop
the goal here is that both things
predict the same representation and that
means the student
has somehow learned that you know
whatever i see here
is a little piece of whatever the
teacher
has even though it does not should
reformulate this because it doesn't see
what the teacher has right
so the student somehow has to from
a very small sub patch it has to know
um it has to output something
that it would that itself or the teacher
which is itself averaged would
also output if it sees more context in
the image
right so you train the network to for
all of these crops and for all the
different augmentations
output the same thing without knowing
what the other thing is and i think that
is
the advantage to contrastive
representations honestly because in
contrasting representation contrastive
learning
you sort of contrast with the negative
with the negative
samples and here it's really like you
don't know anything and you need to
output something
and that needs to match whatever
whatever you yourself would output if
you saw a different part of the image
so you have no choice but to output
you know either the same thing all the
time which is prevented here
or to output
something that's on the image and you
can't just output something that's only
in your patch right
otherwise another patch wouldn't show
the same thing like if you if there's
like there's like a little tiny
structure here
you would not output that because the
other patches don't have it
however if there is something big in the
image right
like you know our traditional cat right
here
and you recognize that because you see a
little cat ear
if you output a representation for cat
um and you know since you would also do
this for the other ear and for the pause
and so on
you this whiskers you then
would you then win like your loss is
small
so you're intrinsically pushed
towards outputting something that
describes the image
as a whole right and that differentiates
it
from other images so what
what encourages you to be different
that's this centering
and also in the soft max there is
a um there is a sharpening
so first of all the centering is simply
what you do in the teacher
you keep a running average here again
you can see that you can keep a running
average of
all the representations that the teacher
sees
right you just you keep you keep that as
a list
or a running list all the
representations that the teacher sees
running average and you simply subtract
that
from the logits down here yeah that's
that's centering
it's something like a normalization but
not really what it does is it it keeps
uh the it keeps the logits um sort of
close in a in a range that's manageable
and and has some variants and so on um
and you know within as
a proxy it also does that to the student
because the student is trained to be
like the teacher so centering is a bit
like a normalization here
and then the second thing is that there
is a different
parameter in the softmax um as a
temperature parameter
so the softmax function is at the end
and that has a temperature where is it
where
are ya this is the softmax function you
can see
it has a temperature parameter right
and that temperature is um
much lower for the teacher than for the
student and they call this
sharpening now
why is there even a soft max that's what
i asked myself like
if you think of a of what you do with a
representation usually when you do
something like a contrastive
loss uh you may just do a contrastive
loss or a self-supervised loss on
the representation itself like you do
cross product
or not cross product inner product
or you do l2 distance between the
representations or something
here we do cross entropy and the
cross entropy after a soft max and the
way i interpret this
is the following um a soft max is
like what you get out is a normalized
distribution
right however we have no class labels
here
so what you do is you simply choose you
choose a number
any number right this is you as an
implementer of this algorithm
choose what dimension you want to output
here
now after the softmax whatever you input
is going to be
a distribution over the amount of things
that you have input so
and you can interpret this as classes
right there's class zero
one two three and so on and you're gonna
get
class zero is probability ten percent
class one zero percent class two forty
percent and
so on right it you don't know what it
means
but you know you um you get this as an
output
and the teacher having this sharpening
it will have
a much more peaked distribution so for
the same thing
it might have a distribution that's
not as much class 0 not as much class 1
very much class 2. all right this even
goes off screen for you yeah
very much class two and so on
and since this is the since the teacher
is the target for the student you see
here is a stop gradient
uh the student is sort of this is a
common
i guess i guess this is a common trick
in distillation like the teacher is very
sure
and that means the student gets a better
learning signal to match the teacher
so this this sharpening of the teacher
uh gives is less noisy for the student
and also i think it also helps prevent
this
i'm not sure so they speak of sharpening
and centering and one i think
one they claim furthers collapse
probably the sharpening
and one prevents it which might be the
centering i might mix them up
but you know one sort of reduces the
noise but encourages
i think the sharpening must reduce noise
but encourage collapse and then the
centering counteracts that
counteracts the collapse
yeah probably though there is an
argument to be made that the sharpening
might also counter collapse
because oh yes that's what they say now
remember so they say the sharp
so they they say uh naturally this would
then be biased towards the uniform
distribution
um with the centering i believe but the
sharpening then counteracts that again
it's in the text somewhere um
i'm more interested in why this is even
a soft max in the first place
so i interpret this as you force the
model
to come up with an within k-dimensional
classification problem by itself and it
has to choose by itself what the classes
are right
so it has to somehow make
representations
that allow itself to come up with a
classification problem that it can
solve and i think that's that's pretty
smart
um you know you instead of giving it a
classification problem
you simply ask it to come up with one
um now this could go horribly wrong
right
but uh apparently if you do it like this
it goes well so
that's the dyno architecture
again we augment image
we augment it in different ways we pull
we put all the things through the
student and through the teacher
the teacher is an exponential moving
average of the student
that gives us different representations
of
different augmentations of the same
image we require
the representations to be
the same in terms of their
so we take the representations we ship
them through a classifier through a soft
max
into a distribution we require the
outputs to be
the same of the student and the teacher
while the teacher has centering which
is centering the logits by an
exponential
running average of all the
representations it has ever seen
and also it has a sharper soft max all
of this together
and yeah the teacher has a stop gradient
so it's we train the student
all of this together gives us a system
that comes up with good representations
and does not
collapse now what does this
buy us it buys us
what i've essentially shown you at the
beginning and also it buys us
k nearest neighbor classification which
are
zero shot classifiers okay like right
now i can i can pump this
through the system pump a data set
through the system
i can come with a new image and i can
simply do k
nearest neighbor i don't even have to
train the network anymore i can come
with a new data set
i can do image retrieval i can do linear
classification on top of the
representation and all of this
works much better than previous systems
no matter the architecture but it seems
to work especially well
with the visual transformers down here
if you see
this for example compared to the
to the best resnets so there's this five
percent difference in linear
evaluation which you know this is 25
error this is 20 error on imagenet and
there is even a bigger difference
when you look at k nearest neighbor
classification which is the
right most column uh they do
a lot of experiments as i said in image
retrieval
in copy detection which is really
interesting uh that's
i think where you where you want to
realize if if
someone has taken an image and made
another image out of it
you know and don't know if that's a good
if that's
such a good thing given that the entire
meme culture relies on it
if you look at this cls token right the
cls token is ultimately where the
representation
that you take comes out if you look at
the attention
heads of that and you visualize the
attention maps
um it gives you this this
not only this segmentation map but like
yeah like not only does it tell you
where to look but it even
seems to be uh sort of segmenting the
individual objects here in the horse you
can you can see the straps of the horse
uh you can see sorry this is a zebra um
yeah you can see there in the trucks you
can see the roads
uh is or the the wheels are separate
from the truck
and so on they do ablations they compare
it with
sort of supervised baselines you can see
this works
much better
and what i think is pretty cool is down
here in the appendix somewhere
yeah they have more of these attention
maps compared to supervised attention
maps and this i mean that the comparison
is is very very strong
um yeah
because yeah so compared to supervised
what i think is happening that
if you give the these things a
supervised problem
they you can see they do pay attention
for example here they pay attention to
whatever uh the cat's face or something
in the ear you can see the the cat shape
however there is this thing
like there is the shortcut learning
which is a i think a date to set
problem but also no supervised system
just
stops kind of learning once it has
mastered the task or
it might it might try out various
optimizations for the task that you give
it
right and and these optimizations i
think are
what you know pop up all over the place
with these
little specks of attention that it also
does
you know these it might not make sense
in this particular image but
you know the same attention pattern or
the same
uh thing to pay attention to might make
a lot of sense
in like three other images in the data
set so that's why that's there
um whereas if you do this unsupervised
uh there's no there's no hyper
optimization
on a single task uh there is no
real like there is only
there's a like especially if you have
also more images
which you can do in unsupervised right
um
you can also can't hyper optimize for
individual samples and so on
so that's one thing and here is this
complete map of
image net i think and maybe you can't
read it but like here's tractor and
right next to it is like harvester and
trasher
um there's minibus down here so all of
these like the vehicles are clustered
together
there is kind of butcher shop and
grocery store
right next to each other this you know
it appears to
be really really good representations
now the question is why right that's
that's the question so this
this was the paper i encourage you to go
read the um
experiment section and so on it's it's
very cool
cool ablations uh they show why exactly
they use this loss and what happens
without
the momentum of the teacher and so on
but what interests me is why does this
give you
such extraordinary representations in an
unsupervised fashion
and i am sort of i have two
hypoth or two things that i think
contribute
mostly to this so if we look at the
question of
why right the first thing i think
is the augmentations
the augmentations have played a large
role
not as much in in nlp in nlp we do it a
little bit differently
but augmentations in computer vision and
self-supervised learning
have a central role and it's really
important that you have the correct ones
which is a thing they also
say right here right they they really
stress that this multi-crop
augmentation is quite important um
so augmentations seem to be central
and to me augmentations are
a bit like that's where you put the
that's where you put the human prior
that's where you tell the model what it
should pay attention to
and what it shouldn't pay attention to
right because all the things
you destroy with an augmentation like
you make the color brighter
that's you tell the model color doesn't
matter right or
brightness variations don't matter so by
augmenting you tell the model what it
should
and shouldn't or you know what it
shouldn't pay attention to essentially
so all the things that it's the same if
you have an if you have a data set
of dogs and cats right and
um you know you tell it you know this is
a dog this is a dog this is a dog
essentially you tell it you shouldn't
pay attention to
you know what is different in these
images you should only pay attention to
what is the same
and the augmentations that's kind of
where the knowledge goes in
so if we want to go towards fully
let's say fully autonomous
self-supervised learning that's what we
need to get rid of
we need to get rid of the augmentations
or we need to get rid of us
designing augmentations for the domain
if we want this to be
you know domain agnostic
and also if we want better image
representations because
the probability that we as humans
exactly capture the correct
augmentations
um is zero right we seem to capture
pretty good ones
uh but you know the probability we have
the best ones
is like zero okay the second thing
and this is a thing that's i think more
hidden
is the data set and what i mean is
how the data set is constructed so these
things are often
you know trained on something like
imagenet dataset
and you can see in these pictures there
always seems to be like an object of
interest
in these in these pictures right even if
you train this from
pictures in the wild like you scrape
pictures from
instagram or whatever uh
the way people don't don't take pictures
of random
things people if if you're you know if
it would be pretty weird to have a
picture
and you know there's just like dirt road
like it's just like dirt road and here's
like
you know a bit of grass and you post
this
on social media and you're like whoa
look at this
so by how you construct the data set
even if you scrape it from the internet
by
how humanity takes pictures you are
implicitly telling the model
what's important so the model learns
how should i say this how you make the
data set
speaks a lot about where
your attention goes and that's
what you feed the model right so these
things these self-supervised methods in
this way they rely a lot
on data set construction
so we shouldn't expect this to transfer
to domains where we get like
random iid data from the world because
these things aren't
iid we tell the model pretty clearly by
the data we give it
what's important what isn't so
that is a little bit of my opinion and i
think that's correct
right i think the model if we have
self-supervised learning
the information should be taken from the
data set
right so that the mod the model should
look at the data and say
no what seems to be given how this data
set is
what seemed to be the important things
in there i
i'm more a fan of getting rid of the
augmentations
so that's my opinion if you want more
experiments
it's you know it's also faster and has
less parameters
and and so on but again dyno is a method
of self-supervised uh learning
where and they their argument is that it
combines naturally well
with the vision transformer right that
was it
from me check out paper check out blog
subscribe
share and bye bye